[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo enlace
norteamérica desde nueva york una ciudad
donde los homicidios con armas de fuego
aún aumentado un 80 por ciento desde el
2019 y la mayoría de ellos han sido
cometidos con una de esas 4500 armas
ilegales que han llegado a nueva york-
procedentes de otros estados al sur del
país como florida carolina del sur y
georgia como sienten los ciudadanos este
aumento de violencia armada y cuál es la
solución a esta crisis de inseguridad
son algunas de las respuestas que
conoceremos hoy además también
hablaremos de un nuevo término que está
generando mucho debate dentro de la
comunidad latina y es latín ex acabado
en x una palabra que nace de un
movimiento cultural que pretende incluir
ambos géneros dentro de las expresiones
hispanas
[Música]
la muerte de al menos ocho agentes de
policía en servicio desde que comenzó el
2022 alarma sobre el aumento de la
violencia armada en este país y alerta a
sus ciudadanos
me quedo en casa por la noche me siento
inseguro ya no quiero salir más por la
noche la ciudad ahora no es segura james
solíamos divertirnos allí pero ahora no
sabemos lo que puede pasar en el 2021
hubo cerca de 2000 tiroteos en esta
ciudad la cifra más elevada en décadas
así que las autoridades están tomando
medidas
la gobernadora kathy hochul ha creado
una agencia estatal para luchar contra
el tráfico ilegal de armas y además se
ha nombrado un fiscal especial para
luchar contra los delitos armados además
el alcalde eric adams ha lanzado un plan
de actuación de 'tolerancia cero' para
acabar con los crímenes en nueva york
quiero ser claro este no es un plan para
el futuro es un plan para ahora mismo la
violencia armada es un problema público
de salud no hay tiempo que esperar
debemos actuar el mar de violencia viene
de muchos y debemos frenar cada uno de
ellos que alimenta esta crisis
fitch de escribir crisis en el plan
participará en la policía de nueva york
cada agencia de la local y nuestras
cortes y el exitoso sistema de control
de violencia vamos a ser partir de a
cada comunidad web cada prisión y
nuestros socios federales y estatales en
haustein intergrupo gracias a este plan
habrá más patrullas policiales en la
calle y un mayor número de cámaras de
videovigilancia en los puntos más
concurridos además se distribuirán
agentes en las 30 zonas de la ciudad
donde se concentra el 80 por ciento del
crimen la violencia también ha llegado
al metro de nueva york el principal
medio de transporte en esta ciudad las
agresiones aquí han incrementado y
alcanzan cifras que no se veían desde
hace 24 años
a este hombre le acaban de agredir un
desconocido se ha acercado a él y tras
insultarle le ha atacado sin motivo
aparente
[Música]
una encuesta de la universidad de
connecticut indica que imágenes como
éstas son las que más preocupan al 74 de
los newyorkinos la semana pasada escuché
que habían apuñalado gente
agreden a personas de la tercera edad
está uno distraído le pegan en la cabeza
me da miedo porque tiene uno que ser muy
prevenido y hay momentos en que cuando
uno va a tomar el tren las estaciones
están muy solas
entonces genera mucha inseguridad
lo primero que he notado cuando he
llegado es que no había nadie en esa
plataforma así que me haya venido a esto
que fue el ayuntamiento asegura que ha
doblado el número de agentes bajo tierra
y el personal sanitario para que atienda
a los más desfavorecidos pero los
trabajadores del metro siguen
preocupados o desamparado hay muchos
mucho entonces lo que tienen problemas
mentales atacan a los pasajeros
aumentados realmente a veces el puerto
han violento incluso cogerla los útiles
que uno trabaja y lo tiran al piso lo
tiran a la vía y esto es algo que
continúa alejando a los medios chinos
del metro todavía hay un 40 por ciento
de usuarios menos que antes de la
pandemia y para terminar hoy les
contaremos acerca de un nuevo término
que está en crecimiento y es latín ex ha
acabado en x una palabra que nace de un
movimiento cultural inclusivo para
referirse a hombres y mujeres el término
viene de las luchas feministas diríamos
pero hay aquí hay unas discusiones
verdades importantes porque cuando se
habla del latín ex se tiene muchas veces
la idea de que tal vez es una imposición
del inglés al español lejos de lograr su
objetivo y unir a las personas las está
separando casi la mitad de los latinos
que viven en estados unidos no aprueban
el término para algunos vuelve a ser una
etiqueta e incluso la consideran una
falta de respeto para otros es todo un
avance en la inclusión de género donde
entra el conflicto es entre las personas
que dicen bueno pero ser latín ects me
viene desde el inglés y yo no quiero yo
quiero usar el español y el español es
ao porque eso dice la rae pero en
realidad en el español existen o
coexisten todas estas alternativas
también hasta aquí nuestro programa de
hoy si les ha gustado y quieren volver a
verlo pueden hacerlo a través de
nuestras redes sociales o en la página
web france24 puntocom